oxygen Beach asks which hurts your
credibility more having no popularity or
faking your popularity thoughts on fake
views oxygen clearly in a world now
where it's much more transparent and
people can dig and it's not just 20 20
has exposed you Steve what do you say
about your fake views you know you know
that world where it happened once in a
while is over now we live in a TMZ kind
of world bloggers Gawker like faking it
is such a dangerous thing I mean what
hurts your credibility is the lying it's
amazing what people can actually get
away with in our society if they own it
we don't care about the adultery we
don't care about the faking it we care
about when you're exposed you lying
about it it's nuts it's an interesting
psychology especially here in the States
more so than maybe other parts of the
world to me it's it's it's basically
faking it and and more importantly like
what about sleeping at night you know
like it's kind of fun to sleep at night
especially today I'm under the weather
by the way everybody so my energy levels
a little bit lower i apologize